Dans l'épisode précédent,
Cyprien se rendit au pays du soleil levant
pour découvrir sa destinée.
Il remet désormais les pieds à Tokyo
sur la planète Namek,
mais arrivera-t-il à vaincre le puissant Freezer ?
Traduction: Cyprien! Le Japon 2!
Enfin !
J'ai passé une semaine à Tokyo
ça m'avait tellement manqué ce pays,
du coup j'en ai profité pour analyser un petit peu plus
ce pays atypique.
Quand tu rentres dans un magasin,
on va te crier dessus "Irasshaimase",
qui veut dire "bienvenue, entre."
Je dis bien crier hein !
"Irasshaimase!"
Un vendeur qui te le dit : "bienvenue, entre.",
ça fait plaisir, ça suffit
mais non il faut que ce soit tous les vendeurs
du magasin, absolument tous
même celui qui est retourné, de dos
en train de ranger un truc.
IRASSHAIMASE ! IRASSHAIMASE !
ok...
IRASSHAIMASE ! IRASSHAIMA...
Et bin non ! Ah ah !
Oh comment j'vous ai niqué sérieux !
IRASSHAIMASE !!! IRASSHAIMASE !!!
Bien joué les mecs !
Il se peut qu'en visitant un temple au Japon,
vous soyez quelques peu déconcertés
par un petit détail.
On retrouve ce symbole sur les temples
ou même sur les cartes,
alors je sais que certains vont me dire :
"Nan mais c'est pas du tout une croix gammée, quoi,
c'est un svastika ! C'est un symbole spirituel en Asie,
Ça n'a rien à voir avec les Nazis
Faut avoir un minimum de culture ! "
- Ok, je veux bien que ce soit
culturel, que ça existait bien avant
les nazis qui brûlent des Juifs...tout ça!
Mais, je ....
T'en fais pas ta photo de profil non plus, quoi !
" Ça me fait très plaisir de te rencontrer
même si ta photo sur Tinder est un peu bizarre
- Mais non mais c'est un Svastika
- Je sais.
Par contre, permets-moi une petite question
Pourquoi la moustache ?
- Bah c'est Charlie Chaplin
Symbole de culture !
Allô !
Si t'aimes pas la culture qu'est ce que j'y peux, moi !
Vous vous doutez bien que je parle pas encore japonais
Même si maintenant je sais dire 'Bienvenue, entre"
IRASSHAIMASEEEEEE !!
Du coup au Japon, je parle en anglais.
mais les Japonais parlent leur anglais à eux
Je l'ai appris en allant dans une boutique de figurines.
Est ce que vous avez une figurine de dragonball ?
Dragonball
Dragon Ball !
Dragonball, Dragonball, Dragonball, Dragonball
Et là je me suis souvenu du générique japonais de Dragon Ball
Oui il vient de dire Dragon Ball... Ouais ouais
En fait ils remplacent les R par des L
et à la fin des mots ils mettent des  U ou des O
Effectivement ça marche beaucoup  mieux comme ça pour se faire comprendre.
Dou Ra Gon Bou Ru
Ahh! Dou Ra Gon Bou Ru ! Directo on your righto (Directement sur votre droite)
Arigato Gosaimas (Merci beaucoup)
En parlant de langue,
petit rudiment de la langue japonaise, non se dit iié
Du coup ne vous la jouez pas à l'américaine
Excusez moi !
Je veux une pastisse
Un pastaga, c'est partie
J'adore la bouffe japonaise
Et contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser il y'a plein de plats sans poisson
Et c'est délicieux
Katsudon ! Ramen ! Udon ! Konomiyaki ! Tempura ! Yakitori ! Paisserie !
Nan nan pas patisserie pas du tout même
Au Japon ils vendent des tas de pâtisseries de toutes le formes
Et de toutes les couleurs mais ils oublient de mettre deux ingrédients :
Le beurre et le sucre.
-Tient, goûte moi ça.
-Oh c'est pas bon.
-Ca a aucun goût.
Ah, bah goûte ça plutôt
Ca c'est déjà un petit peu meilleur, qu'est ce que c'est ?
C'est du papier
Ah ouais... ouais c'est meilleur, c'est bien meilleur
Alors, je suis pas un expert en design, en esthétisme, non mais...
il y'a quand même un truc qui m'a un petit  peu étonné au Japon :
Les voitures cubiques ! Les voitures cubiques !
Il y'en a vraiment beaucoup, énormément, partout, il y'a même certains endroits où j'ai vu que des voitures cubiques
Peut-on réellement tolérer ça ?
Papa regarde je t'ai fait un dessin !
Elle est super jolie ta maison !
*En pleurant* : Mais c'est pas une maison ! C'est une voiture !
Maman, papa il a dit que je dessine trop mal parce que ma voiture ça ressemble à une maison !
Je déteste les voitures cubiques
Il n y'a pas que ça d'étonnant dans les rues au Japon
Il y'a plein d'agents, y'en a vraiment beaucoup
Ah moi je tiendrai pas un jour dans ce métier hein.
Pour une raison très simple :
Mais arrête là y'a des gens qui...
Bah, tient !
Ugh !
Haha !
Et non !
J'ai rencontré Pewdiepie à Tokyo, par hasard dans un magasin alors j'ai demandé une photo...
C'est marrant, dans les rues au Japon Il y'a pas de poubelles
Histoire vraie : Un matin j'avais un papier sale de gâteau au chocolat dans les mains
Je l'ai gardé dans la main toute la journée.
C'est bon j'ai trouvé !
A Tokyo j'ai été amené à prendre le métro de nombreuses fois, parfois c'était assez long, assez chiant
Mais ! Les japonais ont pensé à un truc super bien :
Ils ont des écrans qui diffusent des publicités dans le métro
Le temps passe super vite
Et c'est comme ça que j'ai loupé plusieurs fois mon arrêt de métro !
Putain ! Ah ils sont forts les japonais ! Ils sont forts
J'adore tellement ce pays
entre tradition et modernité
comme disent les gens chiants
Et depuis mon précédent voyage il y'a 4 ans
j'ai pas passé un seul jour sans penser au Japon
Ah ! Je peux pas vous quitter sans vous faire visiter un petit peu hein...
Allé ! On va faire un petit tour !
Un petit tour en rond
Tu viens ?